I gotta ask because like you know we
would we've seen we see like high school
movies and everything like that and in
America there's normally like some
delinquents and stuff like that I gotta
know because like my image of Japanese
school kids is that they're very well
behaved and stuff like that
um is that is that true or not so I
would say 97 of students are very well
behaved if not too behaved where you're
like it's like Social Security it's like
hello is there anyone in there yeah and
so but then you I did teach at a school
once that was a delinquent level school
where they had been delinquent level
school yeah so if you don't there's a
score that all the delinquents
conglomerate yeah and so one kid could
have you know had a you know violent
past the other kid could just be really
shy and then these two girls could just
be like I just need to I dropped out but
like you got to teach some and those are
the ones where it's really awkward
you're like today's lessons is and then
somebody back in like titties and you're
like nope that's not today's lesson he's
like ball sack and you're like no it's
not on there do you want to try again
he's just like titty ball sack and I'm
like are you a student you look 31.
he'll be like oh
and then he'll like leave or something
you're like okay those you do get kids
like I remember one I we had a group
photo right and I felt so bad for this
co-teacher she's quite young and she was
like 24 25 and we taught this course and
all of them were a sports course so they
were like really into all of the things
that a you know a hot-blooded young man
will be into and and you know that's not
great to be in that scenario with this
poor young teacher and we took a group
photo and right at the last second three
of the baseball boys dropped their pants
and they're just like in their Whitey
tighties just posing and this is like
for the school and I'm like we can't
have that let's try taking that again
yeah and then six kids took their pants
off oh no I was like all right that's
I'm getting fired I was like they're
like how was your English lesson I was
like well we stripped and then kids were
swinging their you know those kids are
very rare but I think once they learn a
bad word oh man or they'll be they'll
say like Peter Sensei and I'll be like
yeah he's like and I'm like what's that
word and it's boobs yeah and I'll be
like I've never heard then he's like I
was like no I've eaten the top he's like
and you're like uh I've never heard that
and then they'll just keep digging it
deeper and to get a reaction
so you could say to yourself uh oh I
sound like YouTube comments yeah yeah
well those kids are they're they're
they're memorable but it's pretty rare
because I'd say most kids are extremely
well behaved right yeah yeah but you do
get some characters who who want to
learn about the different words of
they've seen on a an American TV show or
right or they watch this podcast or you
know they've learned some new words yeah
yeah that part can be tough but in high
school at the private one you got to be
pretty straight laced and so yeah yeah
for sure one complaint I often hear
um teachers or Japanese teachers um are
foreigners teaching English in Japan is
that um it often feels like you're very
replaceable like you're you're almost
always made you feel that like oh we're
waiting for you to leave so we can get
the next person in like there's almost a
sense of you you're not valued as like a
member of the team in a sense I don't
know if I'm capturing that question
you're definitely the are we are we
recording this or yeah
listen up I'll just I thought you were
just we didn't stop recording by the way
all right so um
you're definitely not a core part of the
the team in fact a lot of the times
they'll sit The Foreigner group into
their own little square if not in a
different room completely Jesus Christ
and then that's actually better actually
than being a part of the group sometimes
because then you have shared tasks but
the thing you mentioned is I think the
turnover rate is so high for teachers in
Japan that the the the the real teachers
don't want to get a chance to get to
know you attached or figure out your
methods it's just hey man you just gotta
do it and another thing is it's actually
a rule in Japan that every six or seven
years the all of the teachers must
rotate out of the school so you can't oh
yeah this is a real thing so you'll be
is that a reason why I think it's to
encourage not resting on your laurels or
or wait every every teacher every
teacher so you'll go and teach with a
guy like you know Mr uh Ishikawa or
something and he'll be like two years uh
in two years he's gone like that's it
but another teacher was there for like
five more so you you kind of get used to
that or a teacher will come back and
he'll be like ah not squashy it's very
nostalgic I used to work here 14 years
ago and you're like wow okay so they get
sent to different schools and sometimes
that's
literally a horrific change because you
can go from like a really great school
that has model students to a a
delinquent school or or to a tech school
or those are not bad schools but I mean
like you could be used to something that
can be very stressful yeah and uh the
same is for the the foreign teachers we
um unless it's a private school you can
be hired there forever which is my last
job but the other ones you get used to
the shuffle and it's a it's a terrible
dread when you go to the the meetings
and you're like what's my assignment
this year or on the a Kiowa you might
have when I was an AK Iowa teacher for
the drama one I had about five different
locations like all around Japan I'd be
like yo Yogi which is in Tokyo and I'd
be like in kemioka which is the opposite
end of the Oklahoma or you have like a
different day you'd go to a different
Studio Jesus at the beginning of the
year you'd get your new assignment and
it'd be like six new places that may or
may not be anywhere close to your home
they do they do reimburse ment
gotchified teachers
I was like all right this year please
give me the S yeah every time I think
there's something Japan can'tify they
proved me wrong baby I got you got your
occupation yeah
I got that I never got an S by the way
that's a uh that's a I've heard of a few
cases where someone had been uh given
their location where they were going to
teach in Japan and it was so remote or
[__] that they just didn't enjoy it and
they just left like nigata well this is
one of the better ones well I mean yeah
because you could be really remote like
boats or yeah I I had a friend who
taught in the middle of the mountains in
near oh man and that's like really
[__] middle yeah and people would
just leave they wouldn't say anything
they would just I'll go back to Turkey
I'm getting the flight back I'm not
doing this yeah it's especially really
you know Jets notoriously a jet is a
government-sponsored program I think
it's called like the Japanese exchange
teaching program or something like that
but they have great money and great
benefits and a lot of holiday time and
that's if you do want to come and teach
I highly recommend that's the first
option right yeah right they guarantee
you some some money but the thing is
it's the great gotcha of our day you
have very little agency in where you are
placed yeah so you you passed the
interview and they ask you was there any
particular location you'd like to to
teach at everyone says
that actually I've heard eliminates a
lot of the people like oh really because
for a long time Jets were not in Tokyo
until just about four or five years ago
they finally opened it back up but if
you say like Osaka Tokyo Yokohama
they'll be like they don't want you
because they can probably suss out that
you're here for an anime pop-up
convention or like another activity or
something that's you're focused
experience the real Japan yeah that's
that's a quick way but yeah you'll get
people who you know I met Jets when I
was in you got there and they would just
be like I don't know what I'm doing here
I've been here three years and it's like
it's so much snow but I like
snowboarding now and you're like okay
but you're right you could get sent to
ahime which is a beautiful place but
it's nowhere near it's a different
Island it's not very eventful yeah yeah
that's very true people will just that's
how I got my job or no mine was because
of the yeah the other one yeah the other
one the other one the prince Andrew's
stuff
I probably can't say that but that's why
we got kicked out or they got kicked out
but like it was not uncommon
we were okay but like the previous
people yeah
the those
there were a lot of times where someone
would like just be like they just
ghosted even at my private schools right
when covet hit uh this guy this Texan
was like I'm out and he left in the dead
of night with his wife damn like one of
the last flights out of Tokyo and we
have like a full he's a teacher and so
they were like oh Pete doesn't say you
have a new uh you have six more lessons
this year and I'm like well do I get six
more times pay or is that how does that
work are we giving up his his no we're
not okay well he's just literally just
left and he just left and uh I think he
was a little bit concerned with uh the
upcoming year of like what his
responsibilities were he was probably
happy in the job itself and I think he
was like you know what I'm not going to
be here for this covet thing I don't
know the deal I don't know and then he
just gone and he he messaged me he
called me and he was like what's up man
it was like maybe 9 30 at night for me
yeah and I was like dude where are you
at are you at like a studio what's that
he's like that's the sun I'm at home in
Texas and I was like what I was like the
the the cornea virus is like Corona I
had no idea
I had no idea yet it was still like we
didn't know what was going on yeah and I
was like that should still out and he
was like yeah I left man and uh if you
want that TV you gave me I left the door
unlocked and I was like what you live
like you just it's you just you left the
furniture and everything out so yeah
that does happen so Jesus Christ yeah I
know because I it's a big problem right
I suppose you can there's nothing
essentially stopping you from just
upping and leaving and oh yeah Japanese
people you hear about Japanese people
doing it all the time where they just
want to escape they're like sick of
their work or whatever and they just
it's called in Japanese but it's like
it's literally just escaping at night
and just [__] leaving everything
behind just out man and just going
somewhere whether it's in Japan or a
different country take the PS5 though
yeah it doesn't fit in the backpack I
feel like I don't know where this
resolve comes so many people I suppose
the job is that Soul crushing that
sometimes you just wake up one day [__]
it I'm done yeah I'm just like I need a
change yeah that's crazy sometimes you
just need to like and that's why and
that's one of the reasons why like in
this uh day and age like the the process
of like uh renting an apartment or a
house or whatever it is is so strict
because yeah they've had so many
instances of tenants just [__] up and
leaving and then that causes all sorts
of problems to not just like the
building but also like the insurance
company all that kind of stuff so that's
why that's one of the few reasons why
like it's so hard to get an apartment
here because they're like we gotta give
you this apartment but you better not
[__] run away yeah and it's it's kind
of sad that that's like the measure that
they have to take it's uh it's a stark
reality when you enter the world of
Education yeah or just or just Japanese
words yeah